tres nuevas investigaciones una que ya
se abrió hace una semana sea por el
crimen de un
periodista franco ucraniano se trata de
peter szarkowski pero ahora van a abrir
estas tres nuevas investigaciones que
tienen que ver con hechos sucedidos en
tres ciudades distintas de ucrania
primero la ciudad de mariupol en el sur
en la zona de quiebre ese será la ciudad
de osh tom-el y chernigov en el al norte
la jurisdicción francesa explica en este
comunicado además pues que tiene
competencia fuera del territorio
nacional cuando se trate pues de
crímenes de guerra que podrían pues
tener víctimas francesas o de residentes
en a francia y también pues hacen allí
toda una definición acerca de qué tipos
de crímenes o que se considera un crimen
de guerra ellos hablan de cuando haya o
pues se atente contra la integridad
psíquica de las personas o se les impida
acceder a bienes esenciales para su
supervivencia así que ya son cuatro las
investigaciones que ha abierto la
fiscalía
antiterrorista francesa por los y de lo
que está sucediendo en un cráneo